what up guys welcome to the just curly
things YouTube channel today I'm going
to be reacting to something that has
been all over conservative media
um and I actually have an interesting
view on this just because I am a lot of
people don't know this but I do play
Semi-Pro volleyball in the UK
um we had our last game this weekend so
you know um trans people in our sports
or in our spaces is something that
directly applies to me as people I know
and women that I know have actually had
to compete against trans women so um
this week what has hit the news Dylan
Mulvaney and this is an article from
Pink news so you know very very fair I'm
sure publication right Dylan Mulvaney
Troy's trolls are boycotting Nike over
trans ticket talker modeling women's
leggings Olympian Sharon Davis has hid
out an influencer Dylan Mulvaney and for
those of you that don't know Dylan
Mulvaney is a
um that now I don't know if chopped the
stuff off or like what's going on but
okay for her partnership with Nike
describing her wearing a pair of
leggings as a kick in the teeth Mulvaney
best knows her known for her days of
girlhood tick tock series posted a Nike
advert to Instagram on April 6th showing
her wearing the Brand's leggings and
sports bra while relaxing during doing
yoga poses in her home the advert
appears to be a small scale sponsorship
with the brand rather than a large
campaigner modeling opportunity however
this didn't stop Sharon Davies from
slamming the sports bear partnering with
Dylan Mulvaney claiming the pl that
paying the 26 year old to advise their
clothes is frustrating when so little
sponsorship goes out to female athletes
in the United States okay so as a female
athlete guys what what is my opinion on
this Haram I'm just gonna be long story
short Haram Haram Haram guys this is the
thing and I spoke about this in the vice
interview that I did as women we work so
hard and I can genuinely say that
women's athletes are the hardest working
group of people that I know um we we
work so hard for the little opportunity
there is you might get free college and
if you play I'll give you an example so
I I have a friend that was number one in
all of division one for kills now if you
don't know what a kill is a kill is a
volleyball Spike when um the volleyball
hits the ground so she was one of the
best women in the entire country for in
volleyball top half of 0.25 she got
offered six figures in Italy now that's
the best offer I've ever heard of a girl
getting and that and that's one of the
best in the world now she she's retired
she's a family now she doesn't play
anymore but the next person that I know
that got offered a contract overseas
um was a division one athlete again one
of the best in the world and she said
that it was less than a thousand pounds
a month that she got offered with free
housing imagine training for 15 years at
one thing the majority of us can't even
get two grand a month after after most
of us started when we were 10. I'm 26
now I've played volleyball for 16 years
and
um so we worked so hard to get to that
level we spent all all of our Lives
working to get the little opportunity
there is just for them to give it to
trans women and here's the thing a lot
of trans women will say oh what
percentage of people even even do that
it's not that common it doesn't matter
if it's common even the girl
um that who the title was taken away
from last year who swam for pen or
something and she got second um because
I won the entire women's division for
swimming um that's that's a tragedy we
work our whole lives for those few
moments that we could possibly get I
mean I could count on one hand the
number of Championship Games I've played
in and as an athlete we always look back
on those as like our Glory Days some of
the best times of our life with our team
and it's like we work so hard to get
that opportunity just for them to give
that opportunity back to how on Earth
are they pro-woman when they give
opportunity to you will not convince me
that you support women's spaces that you
support women in any way if you
continually give our spaces in our
division tomb and and that's the thing a
lot of these people that act like
they're on women's side that they're
pro-women actively advocate for policies
that are against us um I was on a show
with um destiny once and he he didn't
understand why as a woman I would want
my own locker room why as a woman I
would not want to share bathrooms and
it's really sad because again we we get
into this position where men are
continually advocating for policies that
don't advocate for women and I think
overall in society like women have a lot
of Rights and you know I'm never gonna
complain when it comes to freedom but
when it when it comes to our sports like
there's no reason that men should be in
women's sports so that's that's my
opinion on it I think it's absolutely
just
um I know too many women that worked
incredibly hard for the little
opportunity that we have
um just to give it away
um and actually one more thing I'd also
like to say that most men don't advocate
for this it's actually women is the
saddest part I'd like to sorry I need to
add one more thing the the worst part is
that it's like women we do it to
ourselves like most men men think this
is crazy they think this is disgusting
but as women we don't even advocate for
ourselves so how the hell are the Men
supposed to advocate for us how the how
the house are we supposed to advocate
for our own spaces when like we we can't
even all get on board so so women can we
stop
um pushing this craziness
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments am I right Am I Wrong um
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel and I'll talk to you next
time